morning all uh we start with questions
uh on our route
out of lockdown as we enter the next
stage of the vaccine rollout at the
maxine's minister joining us
shortly but first let's take a look at
the morning's main developments
sky news has learned that some
government scientists are
keen to keep that at one metre plus
social distancing measures in place for
the foreseeable future
boris johnson well he says he wants at
the easing of england's lockdown
restrictions
to be cautious but irreversible
and the institute for fiscal studies has
made fresh calls this morning to extend
the furlough scheme
and also to extend the 20-pound
universal credit
uplift well one area hit particularly
hard by the pandemic
is oldham a town already one of the most
deprived in
england our people in politics
correspondent nick martin went there
to see how families are coping
this is mackenzie he's just turned 13.
this is corby
he's four and this is freddie and he's
free
for jessica degnan heating the house and
feeding her kids during lockdown
is expensive she relies more and more
on the local food bank for help i've got
your food there
how are you having a bad week this week
but i think that was me as well because
i've not been sleeping
and things just going on in my mind the
pandemic
and poverty are proving a toxic mix
one in three children in oldham are
already living in poverty
more than anywhere else in the uk towns
like oldham struggled long before the
pandemic arrived
when industry fell away it became one of
the most deprived
towns in england people's health
declined
jobs became scarce but what's become
clear is a year into this crisis
for an awful lot of people those issues
have got much
much worse a hundred thousand people
live here
five thousand of them live in
overcrowded conditions
living their lockdown out of sight
[Music]
in this house there's four of my
brothers including me
two of my sisters and then my
sister-in-law and then
my niece and then my mom and dad it's a
tiny house for so many
the children haven't been to school
since march and
homeschooling just isn't happening all
you do is stay home locked up
proper hard but they're not learning
much because our home is not the right
environment for you
do you think people realize how hard it
is for families like yours
nope no one realizes the government says
it's given councils 3.2 billion pounds
to tackle the effects of covid in
communities
i think what's happened is covert 19 is
actually
exposed the weakness in our system the
conservative government has given money
that is welcome there's no doubt about
that but they're not giving us enough
money
lovely to see you and i'll see you next
week yeah have a good week on the other
side of town
jessica and her three boys are just
trying to get through this pandemic
but it's hard it's just not good you
know being on your own
like kim's always at the other side of
the form but
like if i didn't have it then i probably
i probably would have lost it by now
mom do you feel like you're on your own
sometimes
yeah this week i've felt so lonely in my
life
in a few weeks time the chancellor will
reveal the government's plans to recover
from covid
for a lot of families an end to this
can't come soon enough
nick martin sky news oldham
joining us once again on the programme
the minister responsible for the
vaccines rollout nadine zahali mr zawi
good to see you this morning um
and plenty of course to discuss about
the ongoing
ongoing rollout but let's not let the
health secretary be the only person that
gets congratulated on this program
we hit that 15 million target is the
minister minister responsible you've
clearly played a big part in that so
well done
thank you very much neil and it's an
incredible team
that has delivered that target um not
least
brigadier phil prosser and 101 logistics
brigade but of course the nhs the gps
the nurses the pharmacists
the volunteers the army of vaccinators
uh and of course the volunteers
marshaling people making sure those four
cohorts those most vulnerable people off
of the vaccine
and uh were able to get through vaccine
sites in as smooth a way as possible so
i stand on the shoulders of of heroes
and i feel in many ways
like a bit of an imposter but we we
focus on making sure now we deliver the
next target
which is we offer the vaccine to
all five to nine uh cohorts so that's um
in total we'll be at 32 million people
with the first dose and of course
the second dose this week is the first
sweet meal where
we've been able to with the supply
stabilizing
send out the schedules over the next
three weeks for people to begin
uh of course to deliver for cohort five
and six but also
to book in the second doses which will
begin in hospital hubs
uh uh in the final week of february and
then in
uh primary care and gps from the 1st of
march onwards
um can we then minister perhaps talk
just a little about a subject that i
know
is concerning you vaccine hesitancy an
interesting
piece of information that did not cross
my radar i have to admit
that some people within the the black
and minority ethnic asian and minority
ethnic communities are saying that
they are concerned about taking the
vaccine because they're concerned
that it may affect fertility they're a
concern that it may affect them
if they are pregnant can you speak
directly to that and provide some some
reassurances
absolutely uh there is a tsunami of
disinformation misinformation which
we have a unit across government that is
dealing with the
uh technology platforms to take down
some of this fake news
uh in terms of effects on fertility it
does not
uh in terms of a pregnancy you can have
your vaccine
of course once you've had a discussion
with your clinician
to make sure that your own um you know
physiology allows you to do that it's
one of the issues that simon stevens the
chief executive of the nhs addressed
last night which is
this sort of the pandemic itself and
then a pandemic of misinformation
or as i just referred to a tsunami of
misinformation
on social platforms and it's very
important that we continue
to deliver accurate information in
people's
own languages but of course in their
communities we're translating everything
into
20 languages from arabic to farsi to
hindu to
polish across the board we have to reach
those hard to reach groups because
although
and you've heard me say this before
vaccine positivity in the uk
so people adults saying they will take
the vaccine
is at 89 of the adult population
the 11 percent that are vaccine hesitant
or
have questions skew heavily towards
some of the ethnic communities the black
and afro-caribbean communities the
indian and pakistani and bangladeshi
communities
and we are working with those community
leaders we've put 25 million pounds to
work
through local government and of course
most importantly i i
published the uptake strategy on
saturday
sharing data with local government the
nhs
and local government working hand in
hand to make sure we reach
those groups with the information and of
course the
access one of the things we've found
neil is actually
a lot of people want easier access to be
able to go and get vaccinated so
we are assessing lots of pop-up sites
uh at least 200 new faith group
sites have come forward and we're
looking at those as well we're already
vaccinating in
the hikma center in batley that the pm
visited and of course
the abbas mosque in birmingham and
cathedrals around the country
it's about access that i think we will
be our focus on that
and data sharing will hopefully get us
to the high levels of
acceptance from black and ethnic
minority communities
those those faith centers being used for
vaccination i'm sure
will advance the the campaign against
disinformation
but again a suggestion a very specific
suggestion coming from within the muslim
community
is that there are perhaps significant
numbers of people not taking
the first dose of the vaccine because
they're
second those would fall and it would
fall in ramadan now i i don't know
enough about
islam to say whether or not this is
something that would be prescribed by
islam but clearly
there are concerns again speak very
specifically to this community if you
can minister
yeah very much so uh neil so
of course we make um already
uh plans for ramadan when people are
fasting
uh and make sure that as we do uh
with your other communities uh look into
their festivals uh purim is almost upon
us for the
uh jewish community and of course uh
ramadan
is something that we've got to make sure
that the system adjusts to be able to
deal with that
but faith leaders in the muslim
community have come out
very clearly whether it's the east
london mosque or the abbas
mosque in birmingham and said that
actually you have to come forward and
take your vaccine
it protects you we know that the amy
communities
are disproportionately impacted by this
virus so
come forward and take the first dose and
we'll make sure that
we will accommodate any issues around
ramadan or any other religious festival
to make sure that you can get your
second dose safely and in the correct
way
good to hear minister um i i wonder if
we can talk about some of the measures
that were
were introduced pretty much first in a
response to kovaid 19 social distancing
and mask wearing a suggestion picked up
by our deputy political editor sam coats
you know that the scientists advising
the government are wanting to see those
measures kept in the for the
for the foreseeable future are you
minded
to see that happen i mean i suppose that
the point is that
you know people have been hearing
ministers talking about a return to
normality
for many people social distancing not
being able to hug your friends
wearing a face mask that doesn't fall
within
plenty of people's definition of of
normal
you you're absolutely right we are all
pro-social animals
um you know it's in our dna that we
want to socially interact we want to hug
our children our grandchildren
uh are our friends i would say this
we have to be data driven uh
rather than just date driven you know we
have to follow the
the evidence from sage
from the scientists to make sure that
you know if
we are able to control this virus better
obviously our
our main um you know our way out of this
pandemic is our vaccination program
which we are we're making sure that we
deliver
as quickly as possible protecting the
most vulnerable and then moving to the
whole of the adult population
you know we want to be able to uh by
september have offered the vaccine to
the whole of the adult population
but with that level of vaccination
which hopefully we'll see the data on uh
you know infection rates coming down
transmission there's some good data from
oxford but we're uh that has to be
peer-reviewed and we wait for our own
data from the
public health england uh surveys that
are being conducted
but with that surge testing
tracing and isolation and any other
measures whether it's mass squaring
or social distancing i think we have to
be driven by the data
rather than just dates uh that's that's
my message
to to uh your viewers is if we look at
the evidence
and share that evidence uh people are
are you know
able to make those decisions uh for
themselves and i think that's the right
way
to do that the prime minister will be
saying more on this on the 22nd of
february in terms of the roadmap back to
reopening schools hopefully on the 8th
of march and then gradually reopening
our economy
but it has to be data-driven
evidence-driven rather than just
relying on on what we all want to see
because we're all anxious to want to get
our lives back and
our economy back on its feet as quickly
as possible
and again this this kind of all takes us
back to to the prime minister
repeating yesterday something that he
said before the case numbers are going
to be incredibly
important in determining which measures
are relaxed and so on
i i suppose the question there is that
we are testing more than we ever have
done which is
undeniably going to register more cases
just because of that i mean if we look
back to when case numbers were low
last summer july the 4th when the pubs
reopened it was 624 cases
that we were registering with far fewer
tests
going on than there are now so i'm just
wondering what kind of level do we need
to bring it down to
before we start talking about what we're
going to be hearing you know
next monday well i think you're you're
you're right to look at uh whether it's
case numbers and
you're absolutely right to say that we
are now uh both in terms of capacity
at about 800 000 pcr capacity
tests a day and of course the level of
testing you know
we're we're almost touching that on
average a week about you know
six to seven hundred thousand tests uh a
day
uh per week as well as of course many
many
uh more lateral flow tests through local
government through
businesses uh as well as
uh people in the nhs and and in the
healthcare system having those
twice a week tests to make sure that we
remain on top of the virus but again the
prime minister's right to say
that where we are today in terms of
number of people in hospital
in terms of case numbers per day it's
still
far too high and we want to make sure we
bring that right down but i'm
you know i wouldn't want to speculate on
this
until we see more data and of course
ask those who are expert the the
scientists the
sage and of course the uh chief medical
officer
to look at this and to advise us
accordingly
and be data driven we all want the same
thing that we want
to make sure we reopen the economy as
quickly as possible
but of course make sure that it is
sustainable that's the important thing
uh hence why we've got such a strong
vaccination
uh deployment campaign but also the
prime minister's already asked us
to think about not just this vaccination
deployment
but what will happen if we need a
booster in the autumn which we're
planning
uh for and of course then an annual
vaccination
program uh for future years if we have
to
uh deliver that if the virus began has
mutated to to a level where we need
vaccine variants and of course annual
uh vaccination programs all of that will
be
discussed in the mix and of course uh
the pm will set out
at the road map on the 22nd of february
based on the level just
just interrupt sorry to interrupt
minister but just one thing that the
prime minister did mention yes the
lateral flow test
to essentially enjoy a night out now
there are a couple of problems with that
obviously case numbers are far too high
for mass use of lateral flow also are we
really going to be testing people
for access when there are so many false
positives
yeah well so false negatives i should
say
yes and i got your uh point absolutely
right so
i think uh what the prime minister
actually said
is it will be a combination a
combination of the national vaccination
program
becoming you know really successful
reaching that 89
of the adult population where currently
according to all the surveys including
the office for national statistics
survey
that uh you know 85 percent of the
adults say they will take the vaccine
the latest stats i saw i think from
ipsos mori said 89 said they will take
the vaccine
so what he was talking about is a world
where
we have you know the adult population
vaccinated
uh to those high levels and then rapid
testing technology
where you can get a quick test done and
then be able to use that as a way of
reopening
whether it be theaters or the rest of
the economy
got to let you go minister as always
good to have you on the program thanks
again
thank you very much
time as always to bring in our political
correspondent this morning kate mccann
at back in the studio
and lots i think actually from the
minister there what left out to you
i think really the overall approach is
what strikes me it's that word
sustainable that's what nadine sahar we
spoke to you about there when he was
talking through the criteria for
unlocking it's all about doing this
slowly making sure there's evidence and
the reason behind that is because the
government is so determined
that this is the last lockdown that
doesn't need to be any strict measure
like this again
in place now that's a pretty big thing
to say and of course the prime minister
last night couldn't go as far as to
guarantee there'd never be another
lockdown
but that's the aim that's what they're
all working towards and you can really
hear that
behind the scenes of what nadim zahawi
is talking about there because
everything he's saying to you is very
cautious
there's all that kind of caveated
information in there about testing but
also vaccination
nothing is straightforward anymore and
previously i think things had maybe been
a little bit black and white what we're
seeing now is a much more complex
picture and crucially on what you were
asking him about vaccine hesitancy
that's going to become a bigger issue
because of what he said at the end there
that they're relying on vaccination to
be able to unlock society so
really cracking that issue getting clear
information out to the right communities
quickly
is going to be one of the most important
jobs of ministers in the next couple of
weeks
certainly well okay many thanks indeed
uh but as we were discussing with the
minister and
indeed with just just discussing with
kate there are still concerns
about uptake of the vaccine amongst some
communities the head of nhs england has
warned of a pandemic of disinformation
did say progress is being made in black
and south asian communities
ashley horinak spoke to two shoppers in
east london
worried about having the vaccine i'm
planning for a family in future and the
rumor saying that that
it can affect your fertility so
that's the main factor i heard um
you feel restless if after taking this
vaccine if someone told you that wasn't
true it's
it's okay to take it would that change
your mind
yeah if so
if said doctor said yeah
now two raids two illegal parties
one a nightclub completes with a vip
room and 115 ravers
the other makeshift pub called the coved
arms police have released video of the
two big busts in birmingham where
revellers tried to escape justice
by running across the rooftops melina
veselinovich has the detail
the front line of the crackdown on covet
rule breakers
police in birmingham raid an illegal
nightclub in the heart of the city
complete with its own vip area
150 people were inside and some revelers
pelted officers with bottles
before trying to escape by climbing the
roof
[Applause]
70 people will find 200 pounds and
police say the dj could face a 10 000
pound penalty for breaking lockdown
rules
eight miles down the road in dudley port
detectives were tipped off about a
covered arms
a car garage converted into a makeshift
pub
[Music]
you might turn that off for us please if
i put it bluntly
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
eleven twelve thirty a dozen drinkers
were allowed to leave
the owner was fined a thousand pounds
the police crackdown on mass gatherings
has been stepped up across the country
during the pandemic
back in august officers dispersed this
illegal wave in birmingham
where two marquis had been set up and
just 10 days ago
police broke up a party attended by more
than 150 students on campus in sheffield
back in back here everybody backing
everybody in back in and as hopes grow
for an easing of restrictions soon
authorities are keen to emphasize that
sticking to the rules
is more important than ever milena
vasilinovic
sky news
i still to come on the programme is now
the time for a rethink on
travel corridors or perhaps ceilings
i'll be speaking to the head of brittany
ferries at
25 to 8. quarter past eight will be
speaking to the mayor of london
for his thoughts about how the capital
should come out of the lockdown
and at quarter tonight i'll be speaking
to the composer and the
lyricist behind a new musical drama
putting the windrush scandal on stage
uh some of the days other news now and
military personnel who were stripped of
their medals
because of their sexual orientation are
to have them restored
the ban on lgbt plus people serving in
the armed forces was lifted into
the year 2000. the veterans minister
johnny mercer says
it's a chance to write a historic role
where we have had discriminative
policies like this i i apologize i
apologize for those experiences
um and i hope today's announcement goes
some way and clearly it will never go
all the way but some way to
redress some of the pain that has been
caused over the years by that policy of
discriminating against
lgbt plus community
two disused army barracks currently
being used to accommodate asylum seekers
face inspection today after concerns
about conditions
the home secretary pretty patel has
defended the use of penalty camp in
pembrokeshire
and napier barracks and kent to house
migrants
saying the accommodation is suitable
campaigners say that they are
not fit for purpose
here's something to send some shivers
down your spine after days of sub-zero
temperatures in amsterdam people
have been skating on the city's canals
the first time it's been possible since
2018
one brave skater startled onlookers by
gliding down the main canal in
just as boxers
rather you than me mate the uk tabloids
have dubbed it the
royal soap opera this is the news that
harry and megan have agreed
to an intimate interview with oprah
winfrey but just how far will they go
on spilling the beans about the royal
family our u.s correspondent greg milam
reports
there are benefits to living in the
celebrity enclave of montecito
walls to keep out the prying eyes and
the world's most famous interviewer
as a neighbour oprah winfrey once a
wedding guest
now the host of the interview and in
america
that's big news so what can we expect
in the united states oprah winfrey is is
royalty
where she really excels at is getting
emotional and sort of connecting
on an emotional level with some of her
subjects and i think that's where you'll
probably see
some some moments of of uh you know
perhaps tears
i don't think she's there to grill uh
the duke of duchess and i don't think
that was
why they agreed to do this interview
famously of course they did once seem to
want out of the limelight
for those who question how you can be
high profile on one hand and expect the
total privacy of
living somewhere like this on the other
well welcome to hollywood that is what
a-listers here have come to expect and
what they generally get
this family though has something none of
them have
megan and harry are not just another
celebrity couple here
the royal thing over here is a totally
different level has a
totally different cachet and they have
access as royals
to anyone they want here so will the
locals
be watching that interview no
i did watch i watched a lot of the crown
in quarantine so i do feel like i'm like
somewhat vested in the royal family at
this point but uh
no i don't think it'll be appointment
television for me i'm not one of those
royal chasers i know people who are uh
you know
living and breathing by that kind of
stuff but now they're in the community
and they seem like lovely human beings
i have better things to worry about than
the duke and duchess of sussex
but for millions it will be must-see tv
greg milam sky news montecito in
california
time to check in see how the weather is
looking this tuesday nas is standing by
and i'm told nas
mild and wet yes
mild and wet or wait you can combine
that to be wild
anyway it is looking mild and wet let's
look at the details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning mild atlantic air is going
to cause temperatures to rise this week
up into the mid to high teens for some
southern areas
into the weekend but with it it is going
to be unsettled as well in fact this
morning
there are spells of rain across parts of
northeast england
just clearing from the east of wales the
midlands and central southern england
also rain just about clearing from the
northeast of scotland perhaps
still lingering for a time this morning
across shetland and orkney
blustery showers across northwest
scotland and showers over western parts
of ireland
otherwise it's a mainly dry and bright
and mild start this morning
that rain will be slowly edging its way
eastwards over central southern eastern
parts of england
taking some time to clear from the
southeast of england this afternoon so
staying quite
dull and wet there this afternoon but
for a time from the west it will be
brighter but those showers over western
island will be spreading eastwards with
heavy downpours and later towards
wales and england so it will be wet at
times across these areas with those
heavy showers
then after that island of northern
ireland will become drier i think the
driest and brightest conditions today
will be across scotland except for the
northwest where it will be blustery
and with showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
wild uh still to come on sky news
breakfast i'll be hearing from the
immigration service union for their
views on quarantine
and indeed the safest way to bring back
international travel in the future
the nature of warfare is changing
an invisible enemy is on the rise in a
gray zone
between war and peace it's a global
battlefield
that thrives on deniability the weapons
of choice
include disinformation intimidation and
cyber attacks
everyone's a target into the gray zone
from sky news
warfare is changing and now we're all on
the front line
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts
only about half a mile from the turkish
coast and
it's evident that is the boat seriously
overcrowded
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
that's it it got us then
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin
and very frail her arms look at her arms
i can
put my entire hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
once it takes hold it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it and get
on top of it and put it
the out largest folds now down to a
charcoal in places
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
oh
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back uh as per usual let's take
a look at the latest data we have for
coronavirus here in the uk
there have been 9765 new confirmed
positive cases in the last 24 hours
that's the first time that figure has
been below 10 000 since the start of
october
a further 230 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
for covert 19 bringing the uk total
to 117 396.
so far though 15.3 million first doses
of a vaccine
have been administered and the vaccines
minister nadim zahawi has said he'll be
watching data
not dates when it comes to start
unlocking covert restrictions across
england
speaking to the program earlier he said
he wanted to see the evidence that it's
safe to start unlocking
and meeting friends and relatives again
not to go by
a set time scale it's in our dna that we
want to socially interact we want to hug
our children our grandchildren
are our friends i would say this
we have to be uh data driven
uh rather than just date driven you know
we have to follow the
the evidence from sage
from the scientists to make sure that
you know if
we are able to control this virus better
obviously our
our main um you know our way out of this
pandemic is our vaccination program
which we are we're making sure that we
deliver
as quickly as possible protecting the
most vulnerable and then moving to the
whole of the adult population
we want to be able to by september have
offered the vaccine to the whole of the
adult population
well in common with many countries the
uk's travel industry is
at a near standstill the new quarantine
rules are biting for people entering the
country
and you have to be legally permitted to
travel abroad and that means
of course no holidays uh so when
might travel corridors return uh joining
us now is uh
lucy morton professional or professional
officer for the
immigration service unit uh lucy great
to have you on the program this morning
um just give us an idea um what your
members are telling us that which they
have seen over the weekend and
and indeed the the past couple of days
understand there was a huge pressure on
our borders at the weekend of course
when people were trying to get in
before the new quarantine restrictions
were applied
yeah we did see a lot of travel over the
weekend understandably whenever you
announce
a cut-off date like this uh people will
travel
in advance of it that's quite
understandable yesterday was quite quiet
uh only a few hundred uh arrived they as
far as
we know they all pre-booked uh they were
all handed over to quarantine management
services they all moved on
and of course viewers would have seen uh
the media coverage talking to them in
their hotels and things yesterday
they were expressing concerns and
rightly so that they were mixing
so they traveled on the aircraft without
being segregated they mixed
in the airport all the way through that
process and they were only sort of
separated off
after they'd passed through the border
checks
what then is the role of of the
immigration officials standing at that
particular border check to what extent
are they being asked to
you know verify negative covert tests
what to what extent are they being asked
to check that passengers haven't
traveled through red list countries
you're in the relatively recent past
uh they check they ask the questions uh
their role
is to ensure that the individual is
qualifies for entry into the uk
but actually at the moment that's a very
minor part of what the border force
staff are doing
so they check that the passenger locator
form has been completed
that the two test packages have been
booked and paid for
if they've been in a red list country
and they've declared it of course
that they've booked the quarantine hotel
so that they can be handed over
to the management services for that
they'll ask have you been
any of these countries in the last 10
days
as best we can if people lie to us it
might be that
they can check that by looking at the
passport there might be entry stamps
uh it does make the interaction a bit
slower and of course that does
inevitably particularly heathrow lead to
cues
do we have any idea obviously it's very
early days in terms of this particular
part of the government's response at the
borders but we have any idea
how many people are trying to be perhaps
a little bit fly to get through the
border
no it's inherently unknowable actually
we can't know
how many people evade our checks in one
way or another uh
but at the moment we're less than 24
hours in uh but at the moment it appears
that people are complying or if they are
not complying we haven't caught them yet
do you think that immigration officers
are completely 100
in command of what it is that they are
supposed to be doing what they are being
tasked to do by the government and all
of this
this is not a criticism of of your
members perhaps just a
a suggestion that the information that
was coming from central government might
not have been 100 percent helpful
the the things that the staff are being
asked to check they can check what is
there at face value
but what we don't have is any broader
capacity
to check that the information that we've
been given is true
so you can download a negative covid
certificate off the internet you don't
even have to go on the dark web to do it
you can get it off of google there's no
international standards so we have to
take that at face value
they've got a bit of paper that's been
typed up on a computer that says there's
a negative test
we can't go any further than that there
is no way to do that
we can't verify an address people can
tell us that they're coming to stay at
123 puddle lane but we can't verify that
that exists
and once they leave the border control
area we don't have any further
involvement in checking that they go to
where they're supposed to be going
or that they stay there and don't come
out obviously if they go to a hotel
that is a little bit more controlled but
again not border forces responsibility
that rests with the public health
authorities uh lucy morton
for the immigration service uni great to
see you this morning thanks for being
with us
thank you very much all right so
what news then for the travel industry
per se as the vaccinations program
grant gathers pace christophe matthew
the chief executive of brittany ferries
joins us on the program christoph great
to have you on this morning thanks for
thanks for joining us and
your organization britney ferris is
proposing a a
vaccination-led travel corridor can can
you explain how this would work for me
well the idea is that given that
vaccination
rate is uh progressing fastly in the uk
in france in spain what we hope for is
that there will be
forward planning by governments to allow
in those areas where vaccinations are
quite high
infection rate decrease and we're not
talking for now of course we're talking
forward planning for
the spring late spring but all these
things need planning and
the idea is that really there are areas
where you should be safe this summer to
travel
and what's very important we believe is
that
everybody is desperate absolutely
desperate to travel
and to go back to some kind of normality
and we saw last summer
how people were keen to travel and this
time around we just want to be a little
bit ahead and
warm and try to also attract attention
from the governments to take a bit of
planning
going forward we're not saying now we're
fully aware that now the situation is
not right
but give a couple of months with
vaccination and all of that
we should plan ahead and we should all
be allowed to have a
summer this summer you're speaking to
someone who enjoys nothing more than
relaxing in the beaches of france uh
with a nice bottle of white one by his
side
at the same time you're talking about
perhaps really this beginning
you know a couple of months time now
we're looking at we're speaking to the
vaccines minister nadeem zahavi just a
few minutes ago you know it will be
september they're talking about for all
for the adult population in the uk to
have
been offered a vaccine it seems to me
that
it might not be this side of the summer
that it could be put we could be
what kind of level i suppose i'm asking
what kind of level of vaccination do you
think
we need to get to as a country before we
can do this type of thing
i think at the end of the day it's all
about the risk population being really
covered because
i think we also need to take a view i'm
not getting into health issues here but
at the end of the day providing the the
people at risk
have been vaccinated both in france
spain
the uk i think it comes to a point where
of course with the social distantiation
that's that's
that's not a question i think there'll
be a moment where it's
better overall that people have a summer
like you like all of us because it's
fundamentally important after such a
period to have that time where we can
all take
a deep breath and and enjoy life again
rather than so my guess is yeah of
course not everybody may be vaccinated
by the summer
but providing there is something like
50 60 of the population and mainly the
population at risk have been vaccinated
i see no reason why if we are being
careful
we can't do it and there are also maybe
type of transportation
and particular areas and of course i
would say that that are more
adequate in moments like that because i
think
it's not quite the moment to go for a
city break but it's more the moment to
go
in a rural area it's more the moment
maybe to take a
ferry crossing because you have plenty
of space on the ferry rather than
other ways of traveling i suppose
as a britney face we feel we have
something to offer maybe a bit more than
others this summer
yeah well we may well get a strong
indication of if this is possible uh
next monday when the
the government publishes the road map
out of all of this uh christopher
matthew
uh ceo brittany ferriss good to have you
on the show this morning thanks
thank you still to come on the program
this morning
calls for school workers and the police
to be prioritized in the next phase of
the vaccine we'll be discussing that
next
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to
the safety ridge what's that podcast for
the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back with the success
of the vaccine rollout
should the government now consider
vaccinating essential workers
such as the police or teachers both of
whom deal face to face with people
young and old every day at work
or joining us now the vice chairman of
west yorkshire police federation
sergeant craig granterson
and the chief executive of the dean
trust which runs ten schools in the
north west taran kapoor
gents great to have you both on uh this
morning um
craig i'll come to you first uh as the
policeman and all of this always
always does you well to start with the
copper i find make the case if you can
i i know friends who are working uh on
the thin blue line at the moment would
be very very happy
to receive a vaccine right now so so to
make the case on his back
um yeah of course uh my colleagues um up
and down the country will be
very very happy to receive the vaccine
at this point i think it's an ill judge
decision
um of the government not to roll that
out at this point
um we are the police there's a number of
occupations
within this country which you physically
cannot do socially distanced
um medical services are one um
the ambulance service social care there
are others
they've all been vaccinated rolling on
from that you've got the likes of the
police service the prison service the
fire service
where we have to physically get close
and personal to people we have to lay
hands on
um for me this isn't just about
vaccinating police officers so they're
safe
it's also about vaccinating us so that
we can keep all the members of the
community safe
we see vulnerable people day in day out
we go from job to job to job
if we've got an asymptomatic police
officer or a police officer that's just
contracted
and the virus then there's every chance
that we can pass it on to an innocent
member of the public doing our job
craig just just a quick follow-up on
that i mean the two policemen that i
know very well
both of them have been spat at by people
who were covered 19.
that's just anecdote of course is that
something that you've heard from
from from your members um yes
uh obviously we recalled um oral
assaults on police and and during the
period of the curve pandemic we have
been specifically looking at incidents
of that nature
we have many many police officers that
are spatter in the course of the duties
um we've had our annual survey that's
come out only recently
that showed that kelvid was being
weaponized by some of our lesser
desirable customers um who were
constantly spitting at us um
getting into our faces um using it as a
threat
um and over a third of police officers
that have been on the front line
during the pandemic of experience though
um
tankarpur of course the the dean trust
as we mentioned running at ten schools
six secondary four primary so there's
both ends of the the kind of the the
spectrum to deal with that
make the case for teachers uh being
prioritized as a
as a matter of priority certainly the
science is veered left and right when it
comes to you know whether or not schools
are vectors for the virus it appears
that they are but
perhaps it follows infection in the
community rather than leads to infection
in the community
yeah good morning i don't think it's
just about priority i think um
it's about making some decisions which
will get the country going again
and giving confidence to parents and
businesses that schools want to remain
open
one of the biggest issues we had
previously was that we had to keep
closing our partially closing schools
because staff were affected by the virus
now
what we have to do at the moment and the
government of governments have asked us
to is do mass testing
of pupils and staff each week if we
didn't have to test the staff each week
we'd have more resources to be able to
do other things
and we wouldn't have to worry about the
staff contracting the virus
and the confidence levels amongst our
school staff would be sky high because
we're striving
for normality and to be honest what
we've found is the country
is the backbone of the country is the
education system because without that
everything seems to have grown to a
whole i can't argue what the
police officers said because they're
absolutely right
my son-in-law's a police officer i
absolutely get it but it's about
decision-making which is looking at the
bigger picture
and the final thing i was saying that is
the
government can't get it wrong again in
terms of opening us up
and then closing this down now there
might be a case for primary school staff
to have it first because
the primary child can go to school the
parent can go to work
slightly differently differences
just on that i mean have your teachers
been coming to you to express
you know individual concerns about their
safety have there been people who
didn't want to turn up for work because
of concerns for their safety
well we've had some extremely critically
vulnerable staff who haven't been in
since last march
and if they're given a vaccine they will
immediately come in so
we've got around 15 of our staff who are
in a category
and that affects the education children
and the pressure on other staff so
yes there's those people there's others
who are genuinely scared
of the situation and i think we can
provide a confidence boost
if over the next month we can get all
staff vaccinated
now i understand the pressure of that
because the second vaccinations that
people have to have and the pressure on
the number of jabs available will be
immense but it's a government decision
and they have to decide
what's the most important thing and you
can't balance the police off with
teachers or
support staff they have to do something
different and think about it
and the final thing on that would be we
can't really open the secondary school
until we know what's going to happen
with the examinations because
that decision needs to be made next week
before decision on school openings made
with veterans
um craig just just a point from you on
on kind of how covert 19 of it has
indeed been affecting things
how it has affected staffing uh within
the police force at the moment we know
that numbers
uh the government is trying to build up
numbers again they're not where they
need to be
i mean have we been seeing some some
holes in the rotors
in terms of policing communities because
of covert 19.
we have in places yeah um our sickness
has been up and down
over the period of the the pandemic over
the last 12 months or so
um i suppose like everything what
sometimes happens is you get an outbreak
um so if you get an outbreak in one
particular area of policing
um then you may knock out um a
significant number of a team or of a
group of people the police that
therefore create some holes um but we
can generally backfill those from other
areas
but it is a problem um and it will
continue to be a problem
until such times as we've effectively
eliminated the risk within the
organization
uh we may well hear uh movement from the
government on this in in the next few
days you never know uh sergeant
grandison uh turnkeeper
thank you both so much for joining us in
the programme this morning
time for us to see how the weather's
looking here's nice
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning mild atlantic air will see
temperatures rise this week but as well
as that it's going to be quite
unsettled we're going to continue with
the often wet and windy conditions in
fact this morning there are
spells of rain that are actually quite
heavy and there could be some spray on
the roads currently
across parts of northern england down
towards the midlands the east
of wales and down towards some central
and southern areas as well as that
there's rain across the northeast of
scotland showers over the
blustery northwest and also showers over
western parts of ireland
apart from that it's immensely a dry
bright but mild start to the day now
the rain across england and wales will
be slowly edging its way eastwards this
morning mostly clearing from central and
southern areas but taking its time to
clear from parts of the southeast so i
think
until around mid-afternoon it's going to
be quite wet there then behind that for
a time it will become
a bit dry maybe even a bit brighter but
there will be showers
already across western parts of ireland
starting to move eastwards with some
heavy downpours again
and heading over parts of wales and
england this afternoon
then it will become drier again from the
west for a time before further rain into
tonight so it's a conveyor belt of wet
weather continuously over the next few
days scotland though doesn't look too
bad the rain from the northeast clearing
this afternoon plus three showers in the
northwest but otherwise mainland
scotland mainly dry and bright
the weather sponsored by qatar airways